c'est ici que va se construire 500
logements en écoquartier à voisins le
bretonneux pour cette réunion publique
le projet a été présenté et comportera
une éco crèche une maison de quartier
des nouveaux commerces mais aussi des
jardins partagés
c'est normal qu'ils s'inquiètent de
comment le quartier va fonctionner avec
eux une idée ce ne soit pas une verrue
mais que ce soit bien quelque chose qui
leur profite a eu aussi je pense qu'ils
ont pu voir sur un parcours très
généreux où ils ont ils pourraient
profiter puisque aujourd'hui la remise
ça reste une friche ou pas grand monde
ne peut aller et puis bien sûr les
cocons répondre à toutes les questions
des usages en particulier la place de la
voiture et de la circulation dense carte
habitants du quartier de la remise
sandra a créé le collectif pour la
remise à cause de ses inquiétudes sur
l'aboutissement du projet de
l'aménagement des quartiers pour elle
peu de réponses ont été apportées à
cette réunion
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de réponse en
termes de transport sur des bus lignes
de bus
on n'a pas de réponse sur la sécurité
des piétons comme on en crée ton
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont prendre un
risque à chaque fois qu'on veut
traverser la route aujourd'hui on n'a
pas de réponse
il ya eu des tests ont été faits qui ont
il ya eu quasiment à mort et aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de réponse non plus donc
agissons pour vraiment sécurisé et
fluidifier la circulation et faire en
sorte qu effectivement ça soit un
écoquartier qui soit bon à vivre malgré
certaines craintes de la part des
habitants
les architectes associés au projet
espèrent que l'éco quartier voit le jour
dans moins de quatre ans on va encore
écouté les doléances on va les intégrer
dans le projet on va amender les parties
que l'on peut amender on va tenir bon
sur scène il faut tenir bon
donc là en ce moment nous sommes en
train en tant qu'ordonnateur avec les
autres architectes de dessiner de façon
précise l'ensemble des différents lots
qui vont comporter les logements depuis
2015 le projet divise mais les premiers
travaux pour le club de bicross ont déjà
commencé et les premiers logements
pourraient être livrés en fin d'année